for those out of the know the snyder
cuts is the uncut version of justice
league that director zack snyder
originally intended for some the very
idea conjures a joy which can hardly be
contained the feeling of hope that the
2017 superhero flake had potential after
all
for others the snyder cut is nothing but
a pipe dream something that can't
possibly redeem what they consider well
beyond irredeemable
whether you're clamoring for it to hit
your screen faster or cringing that it's
imminent to rival the fact is that the
snyder cut really is coming to hbo max
in 2021 under the title zack snyder's
justice league
how it will turn out is anyone's guess
but its release is inevitable
as of july 2020 we've got some
interesting news regarding the lofty
goals of this contentious director's cut
and just what we can expect when it
finally arrives in our homes the july
2020 promotional event justice con
streamed online to maintain social
distancing just like san diego comic con
featured snyder in the appropriately
named spotlight on zack snyder panel
the hour-long interview covered a lot of
ground but perhaps the most notable
tidbit
lasted no more than a few seconds in
answering whether or not the film will
truly be titled zack snyder's justice
league
which to make a long story short it may
or may not be depending on how the legal
side of things play out
snyder commented on the whopping 20 to
30 million dollars warner brothers is
granting him to complete his vision
the director gushed it's just it's
exciting for me to get this chance and
so
i don't regardless i don't look a gift
horse on the mouth i just love working
on it and i would do
you know i would do it for free and i am
yes indeed folks to hear him tell it
snyder is working on his
larger-than-life production of justice
league 100
free of charge talk about a passion
project
generally speaking how much a director
makes depends on a vast array of factors
but they are obviously not alone in the
filmmaking process
that 20 to 30 million dollars is going
somewhere with an army of digital
artists and post-production specialists
likely happy for the work
and an a-list cast presumably getting
some sort of compensation for use of
their unseen acting
but none of it is apparently sliding
into snyder's pocket and seeing how
invested he is in the whole shebang
things are looking up for dc fans and
hopefuls
considering the enormous financial
failure justice league experienced in
the box office and how it was panned by
audiences and critics alike
not to mention that snyder was also
behind the so-so man of steel and the
reviled batman vs superman dawn of
justice
warner brothers must have quite a bit of
faith in snyder this time around they're
not lending him chump change after all
according to snyder himself justice
league was but a mere piece of an
overall five-part arc
similar to how marvel weaves an
overarching tapestry with each new entry
into its cinematic universe
snyder's initial plan may have
introduced a greater sense of
connectivity to the dc side of the
superhero movie veil
even with fewer films under the dc eu's
belt the potential cohesion may have
canceled out how rushed many people
believe justice league felt
the snyder cut may only be a single
movie but it will fulfill some of
snyder's original dreams via its lord of
the rings like run time of 4 hours which
is not absolutely
confirmed but likely as it now stands in
its theatrical cut justice league is
half that long so the possibilities of
what might happen and all that extra
time are right for speculation
one thing that already has fans going
wild superman's black suit revealed
during the justice con interview
i'm assuming you're alfred
knowing it'll be in the film shifts
speculation in a different direction
how will the black suit play a role in
developing superman's character and the
relationships he forms with his
superpower teammates
could it have to do with the comics or
does snyder have a different reason for
its inclusion
questions like these are just some of
the mysteries on fans minds but there
are more where those came from
what about scenes and characters already
established in justice league it only
makes sense to assume that the snyder
cuts longer runtime will reveal new
information maybe even change some of it
cyborg in particular should receive some
special attention if what snyder said in
the past is to be believed
didn't think you were ready for them to
what for them to see the monster
you are not a monster it's weird that
you thought it meant me
and where there's one change like that
there are likely to be ripple effects
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you